a baseball legend an influential Supreme
Court justice and the king of rock and
roll they are among the group of seven
people honored at the White House
yesterday as recipients of the
Presidential Medal of Freedom the
nation's highest civilian honor more
than forty years after his death Elvis
Presley was honored for his decades-long
career as a singer and actor in
bestowing the award
president Trump cited the Kings military
service deeply patriotic Elvis served in
the United States military at the height
of his fame he had a choice and to him
it wasn't a choice Elvis was one of
three posthumous recipients of the Medal
of Freedom
joined by baseball legend Babe Ruth who
died 70 years ago or this war should
have been given to him a long time ago I
said you mean Babe Ruth as it got dead
we took care of that real fast and late
Supreme Court Justice Antonin Scalia his
wife and nine children were in
attendance and Jean John Catherine Mary
Claire Paul Matthew Christopher and Meg
you were very busy Wow
Wow I always knew I liked him the
president bestowed the honor on two of
his political allies as well Utah
senator Orrin Hatch retiring this year
after more than 40 years in the Senate
he liked me right from the beginning and
therefore I like him and dr. Miriam
Adelson the wife of Republican mega
donors Sheldon Adelson she was cited for
her work with drug addiction and
recovery through decades of innovative
research philanthropy and treatment
miriam has helped thousands break free
from their addiction to drugs and to
alcohol and there were two Pro Football
Hall of Famers after retiring from the
NFL
Allen Paige worked his way up to his
seat a Minnesota Supreme Court annexed
Dallas Cowboys quarterback Roger
Staubach was noted for delaying his
football career to serve in the Navy
that's an impressive class I have to say
I was stunned that Elvis Presley had not
gotten never Babe Ruth or Babe Ruth you
know about that and they get overlooked